Dairy 2021, the days are getting shorter, am I losing my mind, or are they losing their minds, or are we all losing our... Oh my god, I was supposed to do the... Hey, welcome to SmartLess! SmartLess! SmartLess! SmartLess! SmartLess!
Dairy 2021，白昼越来越短，是我疯了，还是他们疯了，还是我们都疯了……天哪，我本该去做……嘿，欢迎来到 SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！
SmartLess! SmartLess! SmartLess! SmartLess! Listener, Sean's got a walking boot on. He's got a booty. He's got a booty. Now I got a foot boot. Oh, Sean, you've been saying for a while you wanted to get some booty, and that is just great.
SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！听众朋友们，肖恩脚上穿着一只行走靴。他有一只靴子脚。他有一只靴子脚。现在我有一只足部行走靴。哦，肖恩，你之前一直说你想搞点靴子脚，这简直太棒了。
I got a foot boot on because... What happened? You know, I don't have to wear it, but the doctor said if you want to heal faster, you should wear it. I have a tiny, tiny, tiny torn thing in my third toe on my right foot. I think what we're really looking for is how did we hurt the toe? I don't know. Hang on, wait a second. Let's pause for one fucking second.
我穿着一只足部行走靴是因为……怎么了？你知道，其实我不用穿它，但医生说如果你想好得更快，就应该穿上它。我右脚第三趾上有一个微乎其微的撕裂伤。我觉得我们真正想探讨的是，这个脚趾是怎么受伤的？我不知道。等一下，等一下。停下来该死的一秒钟。
That entire boot that goes halfway up your leg is because you have a tiny torn thing in your third toe. For one little piggy. Why is that the one that didn't go to market? What happened? It refused to go to market? Yeah, what happened, Sean? What happened to the toe? You know, when you walk and your front party or the ball of your foot turns up, I was doing it too much. I guess I would walk too much.
那只一直延伸到你小腿半截的靴子，竟然是因为你第三个脚趾上有一个微小的撕裂伤。为了一个小脚趾。为什么偏偏是那只没有去集市的脚趾？怎么回事？它拒绝去集市吗？对啊，怎么回事，肖恩？脚趾怎么了？你知道的，当你走路时，你的前脚掌或前掌向上翘起，我当时做得太多了。我想我可能是走得太多了。
Oh, so you've got an exercise injury. Is that what it is? From walking. If anyone would have an exercise injury, it's the tight silhouette of Will Arnett. Yeah, look at that. You know, when Jason was... You both were out at the house recently when we were all on the East Coast, and Jason got to see you firsthand. I don't think he believed me that I worked that hard because he's kind of the guy who runs six miles every day.
哦，所以你受了运动伤。是这样吗？因为走路。如果谁会得运动伤，那肯定就是身材紧致的威尔·阿奈特。是的，你看那个。你知道，当杰森……你们俩最近都在东海岸时去过那个房子，杰森亲眼见到了你。我觉得他不相信我锻炼得那么刻苦，因为他是个每天跑六英里的人。
And we know that he's the guy who puts the roadwork in. And then he got to see firsthand that I'm actually doing it, right, Jay? Yeah, well, here's what it is. Okay, there's a basement. I'm trying to fucking cue you up to compliment me. No, I'm done with it. Now we're going to switch it. We're going to balance it right now.
而且我们都知道他是那种会付出实际努力的人。然后他亲眼看到我确实在坚持，对吧，杰 Jay？对，好吧，情况是这样的。好吧，这里有个地下室。我正想他妈的给你个暗示好让你夸我呢。不，我不干了。现在我们要换一下。我们现在就要平衡一下。
Listener, there's a basement room in Will Arnett's fabulous second summer home because of your kind listening. It's my first summer home, but it's my second home. Your kind listening has given him the means to provide. I've had it before. That's true. All right, so now you're working on a third, right? Let's let them know how rich you are, Will. They love that.
听众朋友们，因为你们的亲切收听，威尔·阿奈特的豪华第二夏季度假屋里有一个地下室健身房。这是我的第一夏季度假屋，但它是我的第二套房子。你们的亲切收听为他提供了物质基础。我以前就有了。这倒也是。好吧，所以你现在正在弄第三套，对吧？让他们知道你有多有钱吧，威尔。他们最喜欢这个了。
God, shut up. I'm trying to be relatable. So he's got a basement slash gym in the bottom of the house, and it's all white. I have some wood panel walls, but it's white. First of all, that's not true. The floor is leather. That's true. Let me get to the white part.
天哪，闭嘴吧。我正努力显得接地气呢。所以他在房子的最底层有一个地下室兼健身房，而且全是白色的。我有一些木质镶板墙，但它是白色的。首先，这不是真的。地板是皮革的。真的。让我说到白色的部分。
The white part is the standing punching bag, okay? It's real, real white. It's hot white, and the biggest violation are the white boxing gloves and the white tennis shoes that are down there just for the boxing sessions. So he's getting skinny while doing it in Miami style, I suppose. It's pretty good. Jason, when I was there, Will showed me that too, and he actually demonstrated. So I had to stand there and watch him box for a little bit, but it was impressive. Thank you.
白色的部分是那个立式沙袋，好吧？它是真的、真正的白。那是种炽热的白，而最大的违和之处是那些白色的拳击手套和白色的网球鞋，它们就放在那里，专门用来进行拳击训练。所以他用迈阿密风格边做边变瘦，我想是的。挺不错的。杰森，我在那儿的时候，威尔也向我展示了这个，他实际上还演示了一下。所以我得站在那里看他打一会儿拳，但确实挺让人印象深刻的。谢谢。
But then this is what I like. Jason FaceTimed me from that same gym, running on the treadmill. Running on the treadmill. That's true. Jason, when I got down there, like I said, the floor is leather. I don't want to get into the whole thing, oh, you've got an Italian leather floor. But the point is, when I came down. Is it really leather?
但接下来这个我最喜欢。杰森在那个健身房里用FaceTime给我打过电话，当时他正在跑步机上跑步。在跑步机上跑步。千真万确。杰森，当我走到下面时，就像我说的，地板是皮革的。我不想扯太远说什么“哦，你铺了意大利真皮地板”。但重点是，当我走下来时。真的是皮革的吗？
Sure. Every time I come down there, I would come down there and Jason would be running. It would be a spray, like somebody had just put pressure on the end of a garden hose and just sprayed the amount of sweat that was surrounding. Yeah. You sweat a lot. Yeah. Well, and then what did I do? I take my towel.
当然。每当我走下去，我走下去的时候杰森都在跑步。到处都是水汽，就像有人刚把花园水管的喷头开到最大，喷出的汗水弥漫在四周。对。你流了很多汗。对。好吧，然后我做了什么？我拿我的毛巾。
You did what? I mop it all up, I wipe down the machine, like a guy who's spent some time in a public gym. You know, just courteous. Hey, listen, mystery guests, you can't participate yet. God damn it. Okay, let's get to it because he's laughing. I'm still on the thing that everything is white. No, wait, wait, wait.
你做了什么？我把它全都擦干净，把器械擦了一遍，就像一个经常去公共健身房的人一样。你知道，就是很有礼貌。嘿，听着，神秘嘉宾，你还不能参与进来。该死的。好吧，我们切入正题吧，因为他在笑。我还在纠结所有东西都是白色的这件事。不，等等，等等，等等。
Let's guess. Don't redo yourself. Right there, off to that. Oh, God. He's an actor. He's an actor's actor. He's from Michigan. He yelled.
我们来猜猜。别自己泄底。就在那儿，从这个开始。哦，天哪。他是个演员。他是演员中的演员。他来自密歇根。他大喊了。
He yelled. He's comedic. Wait, he's from Michigan. He still lives there. He made his film debut in Ragtime and instead of listing his credits because it's one of my favorite movies, you're going to guess who it is. Let's ask him about his credits. It's incredibly gifted and talented. One of my personal all-time favorite actors of all time.
他大喊了。他很有喜剧天赋。等等，他来自密歇根。他现在还住在那里。他在《爵士年代》中首次登场，为了不列举他的所有作品（因为那是我的最爱之一），接下来你们要猜他是谁。让我们问问他关于他的演艺经历。他极其富有天赋和才华。是我个人有史以来最喜欢的演员之一。
One of the good guys, it's Jeff Daniels. Hello, how are you? Jeff Daniels. Fantastic. Wow. Wow. That's a booking, everybody. Jeff Daniels.
其中一个好人，他就是杰夫·丹尼尔斯。嗨，你好吗？杰夫·丹尼尔斯。太棒了。哇。哇。这可真是请到大咖了，各位。杰夫·丹尼尔斯。
Let me ask you about the punching bag. Yeah. It's a good workout, but psychologically, emotionally, are we dealing with some shit when we're dealing with that? Oh, yeah. First of all, yes. Yeah. Yes, I have a lot of issues that I'm trying to work out right now. Sure.
让我问你关于那个沙袋的事。嗯。这是个很好的锻炼，但从心理上、情感上来说，我们在面对那个东西时，是不是在宣泄什么狗屁情绪？哦，是的。首先，是的。是的，我有很多问题现在正试图通过它来解决。当然。
Jeff Daniels, thank you for being on today. I really am such a gigantic fan, as I'm sure I can speak for all of us. Same here. Gigantic fan. Yeah, same. That's nice. Thank you. Now, you live in Michigan.
杰夫·丹尼尔斯，谢谢你今天能来。我真的是你的超级巨迷，我相信我能代表我们所有人这么说。我也是。超级粉丝。对，我也是。太好了。谢谢。现在，你住在密歇根。
Not that Michigan is an awesome, one of my best friends live there. Well, you know, right? No, she lives in Lakeside, Michigan. What do you know? It's unusual for actors to live there, right? You hear this all the time. Why Michigan? And why didn't you ever want to leave?
倒不是说密歇根不棒，我最好的朋友就住在那里。嗯，你知道的，对吧？不，她住在密歇根州的湖滨。你知道吗？演员住在那里很不寻常，对吧？你总是听到这种说法。为什么是密歇根？你为什么从来不想离开？
I did leave. Left for about 10 years. New York City. Great research, Sean. And Kathleen, my wife is from there. We're from the same town. Oh, that's nice. We were in New York City for 10 years.
我确实离开过。离开大约10年。纽约市。资料搜集得真好，肖恩。凯瑟琳，我妻子就是那儿的人。我们来自同一个镇。哦，那太好了。我们在纽约市呆了10年。
We had a two-year-old boy. I had about three or four movies at that point, but had no faith that the career would last. Whatsoever. They don't, right? No. So, I didn't want to be somewhere where I'd get the phone call that you're over. Right. And I had heard that.
我们有一个两岁的小男孩。那时我大约拍了三四部电影，但对演艺生涯能持续多久毫无信心。完全没有。它们不会持续，对吧？没错。所以，我不想呆在那种随时会接到电话通知你已经过气了的地方。没错。我听说过那种事。
My agent had said that once. I said, you know, somebody is going to be in the... Do you think so-and-so is a good actor? He goes, no, no, he's over. So... I've been told more than once by one of my reps that, you know, let's start thinking about something else. I've seen people tell you that after a take.
我的经纪人曾经这么说过。我说，你知道，有人在……你觉得某某是个好演员吗？他说，不，不，他过气了。所以……我的经纪人不止一次地告诉我，你知道的，让我们开始考虑点别的吧。我见过有人在拍完一个镜头后就这么对你说。
That's true. And I've whispered it to myself in the mirror a few times. Sure. Jeff, sorry. Continue. No, and that's so, you know, being fatalistic, I went back to Michigan. We built a house for a lot less money than LA or New York and had another kid and kind of used the Detroit airport to commute, which was unusual, but I didn't know how to raise
确实如此。而且我也曾在镜子前对自己低声说过好几次。当然。杰夫，抱歉。请继续。不，就是这样，你知道的，带着宿命论的心态，我回到了密歇根。我们盖了一栋房子，花的钱比在洛杉矶或纽约少得多，又生了另一个孩子，而且有点像是利用底特律机场来通勤，这很不寻常，但我不知道该如何在洛杉矶或好莱坞抚养
my kids in LA or in Hollywood specifically. You know, the joke is I just didn't want them to grow up going to Sly Stallone's house for an Easter egg hunt. Yeah. Why not? I didn't know how to, you know, pull them out of that. So I said, why don't we just go home? And so when the career is over, I can go, oh, okay, and I'll hang up and I'll already
我的孩子。你知道，开玩笑地说，我只是不想让他们长大后去史泰龙家参加复活节彩蛋寻宝活动。对。为什么不呢？我不知道该如何，你知道，让他们脱离那种环境。所以我说，我们为什么不回家呢？所以当演艺生涯结束时，我可以耸耸肩说，哦，好吧，然后我就挂断电话，而我其实已经
be home. Yeah. That was the long-term plan. I've told the kids they're fucking the Easter bunnies fucking late today. The worst one. You know, there's this thing that I heard a long time ago. I might not be getting this right, but somebody told me this, that this is an actor's career summed up.
到家了。对。这就是长期计划。我告诉孩子们，复活节兔子今天他妈的来得很晚。最糟糕的一次。你知道，我很久以前听过这么一件事。我可能记不太准，但有人告诉我这个，说这就是一个演员演艺生涯的写照。
You may have heard this. I'll use my name for example. Who is Sean Hayes? Get me Sean Hayes. Get me a Sean Hayes type. Who is Sean Hayes? Yeah. That's the trajectory of an actor's career.
你们可能听说过。我以我自己的名字为例。谁是肖恩·海斯？给我找肖恩·海斯。给我找一个肖恩·海斯类型的人。谁是肖恩·海斯？对。这就是一个演员职业生涯的轨迹。
Is there a young Sean Hayes in there too? Because that happens. Sure, yeah. That happens too. But Jeff, you have always been a couple of steps ahead in your choices, in your perception of things. I mean, you're just, you've been a pro for so long. And I wonder if not sort of being able to step back to go and work and then be able to
这里面也有年轻的肖恩·海斯吗？因为这种事也会发生。当然，会的。这也会发生。但杰夫，在你的选择上，在你的洞察力上，你总是领先好几步。我的意思是，你真的是，你当职业演员太久了。我在想，是不是因为没有那种能够退一步去工作，然后又能够
not live in this, I also didn't want my kids to grow up in Hollywood, which is why I moved to Beverly Hills. The point is, I think that maybe was there, but do you get to have that kind of… Hamptons for the summer though. Hamptons for the summer. Yeah, I'm not an animal, Jason, but do you get to have that kind of race? We had a Formula One driver, Daniel Ricardo on, and he talked about needing to take that step back and get that perspective.
不必生活在……我也不希望我的孩子在好莱坞长大，这也是我搬到比佛利山庄的原因。重点是，我觉得也许有那种……不过夏天还是去汉普顿吧。夏天去汉普顿。对，我不是野兽，杰森，但你有没有那种……我们曾邀请过一级方程式赛车手丹尼尔·里卡多上节目，他谈到了需要退后一步并获得那种视角。
And do you feel like staying, being in Michigan, you get to have more perspective and that helps you do what you do? Does that kind of recharge your batteries a little bit? Couple things. Yeah, the recharge happens. The movie or the TV show ends and you're still in that town. And other people are working, just not you. That would have been harder.
你觉得留在密歇根能让你获得更多视角，这有助于你做你所做的事吗？这能在一定程度上帮你的电池充电吗？几点看法。对，充电确实会发生。电影或电视剧杀青了，而你依然留在那座小镇里。而其他人还在工作，只是没有你。那会更难熬。
When I did have time off back in Michigan and then I would get a job and you're going to shoot at Warner Brothers, you'd walk on Warner Brothers. And it's exciting and that enthusiasm that you had as a kid for not making a film, but for making a movie, I'm making movies. And it kept that kind of wonderment of when I first got into the business of, you know, you go to soundstage, whatever, and there's a plaque that says streetcar named Desire was shot in this one. I get off on stuff like that.
当我以前在密歇根有空闲时间，然后接到工作要去华纳兄弟拍摄时，你走进华纳兄弟。那让人兴奋，你作为一个年轻人对拍电影（不是制作胶片，而是制作电影）的那种热情——我在拍电影。这保留了那种我刚入行时的惊叹感，你知道的，你走进声音舞台什么的，那里有一块牌子写着《欲望号街车》就是在这里拍摄的。我对这种事情兴奋不已。
So it brought all that back. It also made me different. Jack Lemmon, I saw, you know, we ran into him and I asked him about acting and he goes, you got to be different, kid. You got to be different than the other 25 guys sitting outside that door, right? Michigan made me different. That's cool. And where does it all sit for you today as far as your passion and your investment in,
所以这把这一切都带回来了。这也让我变得与众不同。杰克·莱蒙，我看到，你知道的，我们遇到了他，我向他请教关于表演的事，他说，你得与众不同，孩子。你得和坐在那扇门外另外的25个人不同，对吧？密歇根让我变得与众不同。这太酷了。对于你今天的激情以及你在其中的投入，
you know, emotional investment into the future? Because you've done it. I mean, you've got the gold medal for longevity. You've got the gold medal for quality. You've got the gold medal for providing, et cetera, et cetera. So do you find yourself in a place of sort of that thing that Will's tired of hearing me say, that sort of that sexy indifference that allows for you to be really hireable because they can smell this kind of, well, he doesn't need it.
你知道的，对未来的情感投入，这一切对你来说意味着什么？因为你已经做到了。我的意思是，你拿了长寿的金牌。你拿了品质的金牌。你拿了养家糊口的金牌，等等，等等。所以你觉得自己处于一种状态，就是威尔听烦了我一直在说的那种状态——那种性感的冷漠，它能让你非常抢手，因为他们能嗅出这种气息，好吧，他不需要这个。
He's done it. How does it all sit for you now? What do you want to do? That's the question and that's, you know, I've often, you know, and you guys, when do you know you've made it? Is it money? Is it roles? Is it an Oscar?
他已经做到了。这一切现在对你来说意味着什么？你想做什么？这就是问题所在，而且，你知道的，我经常，你们也是，什么时候你才知道自己成功了？是钱吗？是角色吗？是奥斯卡吗？
What is it? And I've never been able to answer that. And one of those things was that question. When my agent, you know, I said, well, I'm, you know, I got, what's next year? I'm looking at next year. He goes, yeah, yeah, yeah, there's some things, but what do you want to do? And I've never been in a position to do that. Not until newsroom and then stringing them out.
到底是什么？而我从来没能回答过这个问题。其中的一件事就是那个问题。当我的经纪人，你知道的，我说，好吧，我有，明年有什么安排？我在看明年的计划。他说，对，对，对，是有一些事情，但你想做什么？我从来没有处于能够那样做的位置。直到《新闻编辑室》以及之后的一系列作品。
I mean, newsroom bought me 10 years. You were so amazing at that show. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, not even Dumb and Dumber. Dumb and Dumber didn't give you that, because I would have thought that you've always been in that position because you seem like, maybe this is a testament to what a great actor you are. You seem like you sort of, the roles that you play and the stuff that you do is kind of feels like it feels like it's by design.
我的意思是，《新闻编辑室》为我赢得了10年的时间。你在那部剧里太惊艳了。等等，等等，等等，甚至都不是《阿呆与阿瓜》吗？《阿呆与阿瓜》没有给你那种感觉吗？因为我本以为你一直都处于那种位置，因为你看起来……也许这证明了你是一个多么伟大的演员。你看起来像是，你扮演的角色和你做的事情，感觉起来就像是精心设计的。
Yeah, because, because like, to Will's point, terms of endurance, something wild, purple rows of Cairo, you know, newsroom, Gettysburg, like all these things that you've done, which are just mind blowing. And then you have Dumb and Dumber, which to me was one of the smartest moves you could ever make because it showed immediately. That's what you did there, Sean, with the title and everything. That's a fucking classic. Actually, you know what, Sean, you just mentioned the one.
对，因为，因为就像威尔所说的，就耐力而言，《散弹露露》、《开罗紫玫瑰》，你知道的，《新闻编辑室》、《葛底斯堡战役》，所有这些你做过的事情，简直令人叫绝。然后你还有《阿呆与阿瓜》，在我看来，这是你能做出的最聪明的举动之一，因为它立刻展现了……肖恩，你刚才在标题和所有事情上就是这么做的。那他妈的绝对是经典。其实，你知道吗，肖恩，你刚才提到了那部。
So, I mean, Jeff, we met, I don't know if you remember a few years ago, we both, I was on there for a couple of weeks. RV. Yeah. With Robin and that whole gang and our buddy Barry Sonnenfeld, and I remember I kept thinking like, I don't want to, don't talk to Jeff Daniels too much. Don't tell him how much you love something wild because for me, that movie. And you didn't.
所以，我的意思是，杰夫，我们见过，我不知道你记不记得几年前，我们俩，我在那儿呆了几个星期。《房车行》。对。和罗宾以及那一整帮人，还有我们的好朋友巴里·索南菲尔德，我记得我当时一直在想，我不要，不要跟杰夫·丹尼尔斯聊太多。不要告诉他你有多喜欢《散弹露露》，因为对我来说，那部电影。而你没有。
I didn't. I didn't. And I just pretended, I had, because Jason just kept saying, sexy and different, sexy and different. So, I was posing a lot and I was percing my lip like I didn't care. But I will say, I want to get to something wild. Something wild was the first movie I ever owned. And I'll tell you why.
我没有。我没有。我只是假装，我有，因为杰森一直在说，性感而冷漠，性感而冷漠。所以，我摆了很多造型，还撅起嘴唇，装作不在乎的样子。但我得说，我想谈谈《散弹露露》。《散弹露露》是我拥有的第一部电影。我告诉你为什么。
I rented it and I forgot to give it back to the video story. This is a true story. These are the way the compliments come from Will, Joe. This is an absolutely true story. And I've watched that movie, not only have I watched it dozens and dozens of times, there's something, I reference it all the time because I love that character you played. And I've seen versions of it before, but this guy who's got this secret and you take it throughout the whole film and you're really funny and you seem like you're really hapless
我租了它，然后忘了把它还给录像带店。这是一个真实的故事。威尔，这就是夸奖你的方式，乔。这绝对是个真实的故事。而且我看那部电影，不仅看了几十遍，而且有什么东西……我经常引用它，因为我太喜欢你扮演那个角色了。我以前见过类似的版本，但这个家伙藏着一个秘密，你把这个秘密贯穿了整部电影，你真的很有趣，而且你看起来真的很倒霉
and whatever. And then it turns out there's like this whole other twist to it. And this guy's got this burning, he's got this thing burning in him. And I've always used that as a touchstone of a character who's got something else going on. I just, there's something about it that I love, just love. I don't mean to embarrass you, Jeff, but I just love that film so much. Is that a big experience for you making that movie?
之类。然后结果发现这里面还有完全另外一个反转。这家伙心里有种炽热的渴望，他心里憋着一股劲。我一直把那作为具有双重性格的角色的一个基准。我就是，不知为什么我太喜欢它了，就是超爱。我不是故意让你尴尬，杰夫，但我真的太喜欢那部电影了。拍那部电影对你来说是一段美妙的经历吗？
It was great because of Jonathan Demi. I mean, you guys do improv brilliantly. I've never taken an improv class in my life. And Jonathan used the script as an outline. And that was the first movie where, yeah, don't worry what they wrote. Here's what you're, you know, say this, say that, try that, go. And that was a new territory for me. So you got the freedom, as you know, from improv to kind of go, but I never, the secret
因为乔纳森·戴米，所以它很棒。我的意思是，你们即兴表演得太出色了。我这辈子从来没上过即兴表演课。而乔纳森把剧本只当成一个大纲。那是第一部电影，是的，别管他们写了什么。这是你要……你知道的，说这个，说那个，试试那个，开始。对我和说是个新领域。所以你从即兴表演中获得了自由，如你所知，去发挥，但我从来没有……秘密
thing is that sometimes actors will hide it a little bit, maybe a lot, but not completely. And I think I, if I remember right, I just completely ignored the fact that there's this secret that I'm going to get to later because I went into that movie going, the two guys I had grown up with idolizing or at least got me interested in acting were Dick Van Dyke and Jack Lemon. They were two of them, but they were the guys who could do comedy. Alan Arkin was another one. Alan is so, you know, understated and all that, but these guys, you know, like in-laws
是，有时演员会把秘密隐藏一点，也许隐藏很多，但并非完全不露。而且我想我，如果我没记错的话，我完全忽略了这样一个事实：我有一个要留到后面揭晓的秘密，因为我拍那部电影时的想法是，从小到大我崇拜的或者至少让我对表演产生兴趣的两个人是迪克·范·戴克和杰克·莱蒙。他们是其中的两个，但他们是那些能够搞笑的人。阿兰·阿尔金是另一个。阿兰是那么地，你知道，低调等等，但这些人，你知道的，就像
with Peter Faulk, those guys, they could go big comedically and not get caught. And so that's, Jack Lemon and Dick Van Dyke had a baby and its name was Charlie Driggs in something while that was, I'm going to do what they would do. And then I just rolled that into that secret. But you had that, there's a scene in the, if you remember, there's a scene in the coffee shop at the motel where Ray Liotta, Ray Liotta at his menacingly best. First movie. First, first movie.
和彼得·法尔克的《岳父大人》，那些家伙，他们在喜剧上可以放得很开，而且不会让人觉得是在刻意搞笑。所以，杰克·莱蒙和迪克·范·戴克生了个孩子，它的名字叫查理·德里格斯（在《散弹露露》里），这就是我要做的，我要做他们会做的事。然后我把这个融入到了那个秘密中。但你当时有那个……如果你还记得的话，汽车旅馆的咖啡馆里有一场戏，雷·利奥塔，雷·利奥塔正处于他最具威胁性的状态。第一部电影。第一部，第一部电影。
So there you go. First movie. He was so scary. He was scary even just doing the scenes with, he was so good. But you, you have this scene where you kind of, there's a cop in the diner there and you know that he can't do anything because the cops there. So you've got like the freedom and there's something again about the way you played that scene.
所以你看。第一部电影。他太吓人了。甚至只是和他对戏时他也让人害怕，他太棒了。但你，你有一场戏，你有点……小餐馆里有个警察，你知道因为警察在场他什么也做不了。所以你拥有那种自由，而且再次地，你演那场戏的方式有一种……
I was like, this is the way you do a scene. Like I thought, like if I taught a film class ago, this is how you do a scene and that dynamic and that chemistry and that thing that those instincts that you had for me, again, not to embarrass you, I've just always taken with me. It's a strange thing, but it's true. You don't, you don't teach? Well, I should.
我当时想，这才是演戏的正确方式。就像我想，如果我去教电影课，我会说这就是演戏的方法，那种动态、那种化学反应、你拥有的那种直觉，对我来说，再次声明，不是为了让你尴尬，我一直铭记在心。这是一件很奇怪的事，但这是真的。你难道不教书吗？好吧，我应该教。
This is a good point. Yeah. It's a really good point, Sean. And I'm going to, I'm going to put my number up in the chat after, if anybody wants to. You could use it, Sean. That is a, that's a movie that one of, one of my heroes, Paul Thomas Anderson talks a lot about and I've, I've scolded myself for having never seen it yet. But after this talk, I've got even more impetus to see it.
这是个好观点。对。这是一个非常好的观点，肖恩。等会儿如果有谁想的话，我会在聊天里留下我的电话号码。你可以用它，肖恩。那是一部电影，我的英雄之一保罗·托马斯·安德森经常谈起它，而我一直因为自己还没看过它而责备自己。但听了这次谈话后，我有更强的动力去看了。
So Jonathan Demme would, would, if you gave him 10 grand to make a movie or a hundred million, he'd have the same enthusiasm at six in the morning, same thing. And he never met an idea that he wouldn't give it a shot. Yeah. Try it. Go. Wow. Anything.
所以乔纳森·戴米，如果你给他1万块钱去拍电影或是1亿美元，他在早上6点钟也会保持同样的热情，完全一样。而且他从不会拒绝任何一个愿意去尝试的想法。对。试试看。开始。哇。任何事情。
And he was so encouraging. Others have been so, but no one more so than Jonathan Demme was. He was a pleasure to work with. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. One of my favorite movies, like top five is Ragtime. I, I, I tell, tell me, tell me about that. Tell me about working with Milos Forman.
而且他总是那么鼓励别人。其他人也曾这样，但没有人比乔纳森·戴米更甚。和他合作是一种荣幸。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。我最喜欢的电影之一，排名前五的是《爵士年代》。我，我，我，告诉我，告诉我这个。告诉我跟米洛斯·福尔曼合作的经历。
Ragtime was the first movie it was, my agent had been an agent at ICM for about a week. He inherited a client list of which I was on it, one of the people on it. He recently was the casting director for Ragtime. So Paul Martino was, he knew Milos and he said, Milos, you know, yeah, I've started a job and I got an actor I want you to see, put him in the movie. And so Milos, it was perfunctory. I mean, went over and met Milos. She goes, yeah, okay.
《爵士年代》是第一部电影，我的经纪人在ICM当了大约一周的经纪人。他继承了一份客户名单，我是其中的一员，名单上的人之一。他最近刚刚成为《爵士年代》的选角导演。所以保罗·马蒂诺，他认识米洛斯，他说，米洛斯，你知道，是的，我开始了一份新工作，我有一个演员想让你见见，把他放进电影里。所以米洛斯，那只是例行公事。我的意思是，我过去见了米洛斯。她说，好吧，可以。
And said hello and looked at me and said, okay, right, you can play this part, get out of here. That was it. And I got it because of Paul, the thrill of Ragtime was Cagney working with Jimmy Cagney. That was his last film, wasn't it? It was and the story, he didn't want to do it. He was living upstate New York. He was 81 going on 101.
然后打了招呼，看着我说，好吧，对，你可以演这个角色，滚出去。就是这样。我得到这个角色是因为保罗，《爵士年代》最激动人心的部分是卡格尼，和吉米·卡格尼合作。那是他的最后一部电影，对吧？是的，而且那个故事，他其实不想演。他住在纽约北部。他81岁高龄，快要101岁了。
He wanted a screen test and to prove to himself that he could do it. Wow. Milos really wanted him. So this is 81. They rented a studio at Channel 13 in New York City and WNET and we went down there and he got a bunch of the other actors that were in this one scene with the police commissioner, which was Cagney. They got Kenny McMillan, who's passed away.
他想要进行一次银幕试镜，向自己证明他还能演。哇。米洛斯非常希望他来演。所以这是81岁时。他们在纽约市的13频道（WNET）租了一个录音室，我们去了那里，他找了其他几个要和警察局长（由卡格尼饰演）在这场戏里搭戏的演员。他们找了肯尼·麦克米兰，他已经去世了。
He was amazing. He was a bulldozer, fireplug of an angry actor that could just go. I mean, he was just an open vein. The racist fire chief. Yeah. Yeah. And then he added, I think Howard Rollins was there and then three or four of us, other cops who were just to fill out the room and I don't know why, but we didn't say anything.
他太棒了。他是个推土机般、火爆脾气、充满愤怒的演员，说爆发就能爆发。我的意思是，他就像一根敞开的血管。那个种族主义的消防队长。对。对。然后他加上了，我想霍华德·罗林斯也在那儿，然后还有三四个我们其他人，其他只负责充当背景的警察，我不知道为什么，但我们什么都没说。
But I got to go. So you're sitting in there and there's not, there's like one camera and a black and white monitor up on a wall. That's where you could see what the camera saw. No video village, just that black and white in comes Cagney drove down. Here he comes. A nurse is helping him in on a walker, on a walker, puts the walker down, sits in the chair.
但我有机会去了。所以你坐在那里，没有多少设备，只有一个摄像机和一个挂在墙上的黑白监视器。那是你能看到摄像机捕捉到画面的地方。没有视频村，只有那个黑白屏幕，卡格尼开车过来了。他来了。护士用助行器搀扶着他走进来，拿着助行器，放下助行器，坐在椅子上。
It's a three page scene. He can't do it. He can't remember the next line. He can't. He turns the page. It's 10 seconds. It's bad. Again, well.
这是一场三页纸的戏。他演不了。他记不住下一句台词。他记不住。他翻了一页。过了10秒钟。很糟糕。又来了，威尔。
He goes, all right. All right. All right. Let's do, let's do the one page. Let's do the one. And he puts the one page down. There are three lines. Can't do it.
他说，好吧。好吧。好吧。我们来拍，我们拍那一页。我们拍那一页。他放下那一页。上面有三行台词。还是演不了。
Let's do the one. The one line. You do the one line. You read that line. Cagney went over it, went over it, went over it and then he looked up and he looked at Kenny McMillan and you could see it on the black and white TV monitor. There it was, that thing that only guys like Cagney have. The only other guys I've seen that have it that I've been on a set with were Clint and
我们拍这一行。你就演这一行。你读那行台词。卡格尼反复琢磨，反复琢磨，反复琢磨，然后他抬起头，看着肯尼·麦克米兰，你可以在那个黑白电视监视器上看到。就是那个，只有像卡格尼这样的传奇人物才有的那种东西。我见过的仅有的其他几个拥有这种特质、并且我和他们一起合作过片子的人是克林特和
Jack Nicholson. That thing where the camera goes and they become that thing and then they come out of it. They make eye contact and the presence is there and yeah. Yeah. Or just you can see all the movies he's ever done are right there again. He's just old. And that he, we cut after that one line and Milo said, perfect, you got it.
杰克·尼科尔森。那种摄像机一开拍，他们就变成了那个人物，然后又从中抽离出来的特质。他们进行眼神交流，那种存在感就在那里，对。对。或者你只是能看出他拍过的所有电影都在那一刻重现了。他只是老了。然后他，我们在那句台词之后喊停，米洛斯说，完美，你拿下了。
We're going to be any shot at line to line. Just for Tracy Milo Shformin, he directed One Floor of the Cuckoo's Nest, Ragtime, Amadeus, Man on the Moon, all these huge movies. Yeah. He's a great director. Beautiful director. I'm so jealous you got to work with him. Amadeus is my favorite movie.
我们要按句号逐行拍摄了。至于特蕾西·米洛斯·福尔曼，他导演了《飞越疯人院》、《爵士年代》、《莫扎特传》、《月亮上的男人》，所有这些大电影。对。他是个伟大的导演。非常优秀的导演。我太嫉妒你能跟他合作了。《莫扎特传》是我最喜欢的电影。
Can we go to newsroom? Can you? Sure. Now, I think everyone except Tracy has probably heard the stories about Aaron Sorkin and his incredible writing, but in sometimes his intransigence when it comes to actors making the lines of their own. Can you speak to any of that without risking any sort of career suicide? No, not at all.
我们能聊聊《新闻编辑室》吗？可以吗？当然。现在，我想除了特蕾西之外，大概所有人都听过关于亚伦·索尔金以及他不可思议的剧本的故事，但有时候他在演员改动台词这件事上显得非常固执。你能聊聊这方面的经历，同时又不会冒任何职业自杀的风险吗？不，完全不会。
It's very clear. It is very clear what the rules are, which is don't change your word. I've heard you can't change um to uh. Correct. Huh. How did you like that? Uh, it's um. It's actually um.
非常明确。规则非常明确，那就是不要改动任何一个词。我听说连把“嗯”改成“呃”都不行。没错。哈。你觉得这怎么样？呃，是“嗯”。其实是“嗯”。
I had come out of the theater. So in New York where it was, that's the way it was in the theater. It was, whether it was Lanford Wilson in my case off Broadway, you go ask if you want to change one of the words and so that was just the rule. And so your job was to make the writing work. And if they didn't, they didn't work, they'd rewrite it or they'd redo you or something. But that was the deal. But in the interest of trying to make lines sound like they are coming out of thought,
我是从戏剧界出来的。所以当时在纽约，戏剧界就是这样的。无论是我的情况下的兰福德·威尔逊外百老汇演出，你想改一个词都得去问过，这就是规矩。所以你的工作就是让剧本发挥作用。如果台词行不通，它们就是行不通，他们会重写或者让你重拍什么的。但这就是交易。不过为了让台词听起来像是经过思考后才说出来的，
one sometimes, you know, like I'm doing right now, you sort of, you, you, you break them up, you mess them up. Oh, you're acting right now? No, but you know what I mean? Like there's like, there's things that sound natural that a writer might not write because it is a lot of ellipses and a lot of words, exactly. And I'm sure his defense would be like, I know that's what makes me good at what I do is that I understand that and, and there's the also the sort of underlying that is that
有时候，你知道的，就像我现在这样，你会把它们，把它们拆碎，把它们搞砸。哦，你现在在演戏吗？不，但你知道我的意思吗？就像有些听起来很自然的话，编剧可能不会这么写，因为里面有很多省略号和很多词，确实如此。而且我确信他的辩解会是：我知道这正是我擅长的原因，因为我理解这一点，并且，这背后的潜台词也是
I understand better than you. Well, but there's the separation between what is writing and what is acting. And I guess my question is how much is he tolerant of the merging of those two things? You have to marry yourself to the rhythm of the writing, the melody of Sorkin. There is a melody and it's, I call it like writing secretariat, you get on it and you write it. Right. Like a mammoth or even a Shakespeare.
我比你更懂。好吧，但剧作和表演之间存在着一种分界线。我想我的问题是，他对于将这两者融合有多少包容度？你必须将自己与剧本的节奏、索尔金的旋律融为一体。这里面有一种旋律，我称之为像写“秘书处”（一匹传奇赛马）一样，你骑上去然后驾驭它。没错。就像猛犸象，甚至像莎士比亚。
Like there's just, or Neil Simon was the same way. Yeah. Don't change it. Don't change it. And you guys know from comedy, you take one word out. It's not funny. Yeah. I did promises, promises on Broadway, this musical and Neil would come to rehearsals
就像那样，或者尼尔·西蒙也是这样。没错。别改。不要改。你们这些喜剧演员懂的，你拿掉一个词。就不搞笑了。没错。我在百老汇演过《承诺，承诺》这部音乐剧，尼尔会来到排练现场
and rewrite with me on the spot. It was crazy. Wow. And I was like, oh my God, Neil Simon's writing words. I've never worried about the fact that I get what Jason's saying completely. And I'm not advocating for one way or the other. I'm just curious about how, what the process was. No, I know, I know.
当场跟我一起重写台词。太疯狂了。哇。当时我想，天哪，尼尔·西蒙在改写台词。我从来不担心这个，因为我完全理解杰森在说什么。我并不是在主张哪一种方式更好。我只是对整个过程是怎么样的感到好奇。不，我知道，我懂。
But here's the deal. Like Patty Chayevski in network, for example, when William Holden and Faye Dunaway are going at each other in that room, there are three people in that room and one of them is Patty Chayevski. And you know it and you can feel it and you can hear his voice and that's where Sorkin's coming from. He is in every scene. And so my job is to make it sound as thoughtful and as falling out of my head for the first
但问题是这样的。比如《电视台风云》里的帕蒂·查耶夫斯基，当威廉·霍尔顿和费·唐纳薇在那个房间里大吵时，那个房间里有三个人，其中一个就是帕蒂·查耶夫斯基。你知道这一点，你能感觉到，你能听到他的声音，索尔金也就是从这种传统中走出来的。他存在于每一个场景中。所以我的任务是让这些台词听起来尽可能深思熟虑，尽可能像是第一次从我脑子里蹦出来的一样。
time as possible. But at the end of the day, if it also feels written, we like that. Right. There's someone driving the bus. And so you marry yourself to that as an actor and you do your best job to make it as real as possible. Got it. But you know, Jason, we talk about this sometimes, there's that kind of look at the end of the
但归根结底，如果它同时也让人觉得是写出来的剧本，我们也很喜欢。对吧。有人在开这辆车。所以你作为演员要与这种风格结合，并尽最大努力把它演得尽可能真实。明白了。但你知道，杰森，我们有时候会聊到这个，最后其实也有那种看法，也许现在这种现象更普遍了，片场更像是一个合作的体验。
day also, and maybe this is more prevalent now, it is much more a collaborative experience on set. I think that, I don't know if all you guys can attest to that, but certainly, you know, there are moments where, for instance, you know, Jimmy Burroughs, the great TV director who Sean and I had the, you know, honor to work with, Jason's known forever and ever and ever. And Jason, did you guys ever do it? Do you and Jimmy ever?
我觉得，我不知道你们大家是否都有同感，但当然，你知道的，有些时刻，比如，你知道的，吉米·伯罗斯，这位伟大的电视导演，肖恩和我曾有幸与他合作，杰森更是认识了他一辈又一辈又一辈。杰森，你们合作过吗？你和吉米合作过吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Bunch of stuff actually. Oh yeah. You did it. Yeah. I remember one time Sean and I were doing a show with Jimmy, and I remember I can't, I got to walk in and deliver a line and then I like take a drink or something.
对。对。其实合作过很多东西。哦，对。你们合作过。对。我记得有一次肖恩和我跟吉米一起拍一部剧，我记得我当时……我得走过去说一句台词，然后我好像要喝一杯水什么的。
So I come in and I say the line, and then I take the drink and as we're walking way to the next set to go rehearse on the next set, he says, Willie, say you have to line, take the drink and then say the other thing on the other side. And I was like, okay, and I try it and it was like 24% funnier. Yeah. Isn't that amazing? And I kind of was like, huh, I just walked away, he was like, he was so fucking right, you know.
所以我走过去说了台词，然后我喝了口水，正当我们往下一个布景走去准备在下一个布景排练时，他说：“威利，说吧，你得说台词，喝口水，然后再在另一边说另一句话。”我当时就想，好吧，我试了一下，结果发现好笑了24%。对。是不是很神奇？我当时就觉得，哈，我刚走开，他心想，他他妈的太对了，你知道吗。
Yeah. I love that. Yeah. The good one, Jim Brooks is another guy like that. I mean, they just know. Yep. They just know. But they got to see it.
太棒了。对。吉姆·布鲁克斯也是这样的人。我的意思是，他们就是懂。没错。他们就是懂。但他们得亲眼看到。
They got to see you do it. And so that's kind of what I go, you want to see the words you wrote? Here they are. Boom. Yeah. And that's kind of how I go into it. With all your experience, all your set exposure, set experience, understanding of the process, blah, blah, blah, all that stuff.
他们得看你演出来。所以这就是我常想的：你想看你写的台词吗？都在这儿了。轰。没错。我基本上就是这么进入状态的。凭借你所有的经验、所有的片场曝光度、片场经验、对制作流程的理解，等等等等，所有这些东西。
Has it ever drawn you towards wanting to utilize all that by jumping in the director chair? You have. Right, Jason? Yeah. You love it. I can't stand it. Oh, really? God, I cannot get enough of it.
这一切有没有曾吸引过你，让你想要利用所有这些积累，直接坐上导演椅？你已经试过了。对吧，杰森？对。你太喜欢了。我简直无法忍受。哦，真的吗？天哪，我怎么也看不够。
Really? I can't stand it. Why? Because the questions, the constant questions, the coming up and going, is it the red sweater or the blue sweater? I don't care. I just don't care. And so I, I mean, I completely get the, having the vision, but having the, I don't have the
真的吗？我可受不了。为什么？因为那些问题，没完没了的问题，总是走过来问你：是红毛衣还是蓝毛衣？我不在乎。我根本不在乎。所以，我的意思是，我完全理解拥有宏观愿景，但拥有……我没有
patience for it. But having the vision of the overall, of the overall piece, I completely get that that's the chair you got to sit in. Right. What about when you're on the set with a director that isn't as comfortable on a set as you are, and as a result, the process, you know, the, the 10 hours of work you guys might have to do that day is going to take 14. And does that ever just start to eat at you and you're like, well, if I would just utilize
那种耐心。但拥有对整体的宏观愿景、对整个作品的全局把控，我完全理解那是你必须去坐的位置。没错。那当你在片场遇到一个对片场的熟悉程度不如你、结果导致你们那天可能得做10个小时的工作硬生生变成14个小时的导演时，会怎么样？那种情况有没有开始折磨你，让你觉得，我要是能利用
all that I've absorbed, we might, we might treat ourselves to a, to a more efficient day. Jason got into directing so that he could do scenes like whatever would get him back on the 10 quickest. Yeah. Exactly. You know, everybody just stand in a line. I'm going to shoot that.
我吸收的所有这些经验，我们说不定就能让自己过上一个更有效率的一天呢？杰森开始当导演，纯粹是为了能拍那种能让他最早收工回家的戏。对。没错。你知道的，大家都排成一排。我就拍那个。
Is this setup going to put me on the 405? Because if it's not, it's another one or listen, you also, you underestimate Jason's appetite for discussing minutiae and arguing about fucking just details and stuff that's meaningless. Oh my God. He can fucking talk about shit that you're like, we already got it a half hour ago, idiot. And he's like, but listen, why would they, you know, shut the fuck, but you know, if you think about it, it's unreal, it's unreal.
这个机位能让我赶上405号公路吗？如果不能，那就是下一个，或者听着，你也低估了杰森对讨论细节和争论那些无聊琐事、毫无意义的细节的热情。天哪。他能他妈的扯那些让你觉得“我们半小时前就已经搞定这傻X问题了”的废话。而他却说：“但是听着，为什么他们要……去他妈的，但你知道，如果你仔细想想，这太不真实了，太不真实了。”
No interest whatsoever. Here's the other problem of being a director or that I did. I actually wrote, directed and acted in two independent films. Yeah. So I did it. I got it. I, I've been in the editing room. I completely get how there's, that's where you write your final draft.
毫无兴趣。做导演的另一个问题或者说我经历过的问题是。我实际上自编、自导并主演了两部独立电影。对。所以我干过。我懂。我也进过剪辑室。我完全明白那是你编写最终定稿的地方。
I can, all of that. But you wrap principal photography, I'm done. Yeah. I'm an actor. I'm done. You are one third of the way through this thing. And I just, I'm, I'm over it. I, I that, that I learned that I'm going, oh my God, now I got to go promote it.
所有这些。但一旦主体拍摄杀青，我就结束了。对。我是一名演员。我演完了。你在这个项目里才完成了三分之一。而我已经……我已经受够了。我，我……我学到了这一点，然后我想，天哪，现在我还得去宣传它。
Yeah. Well, that speaks to something interesting, Jeff. Do you like that? But obviously you just said you kind of like that, that you're wrapped. But do you, you have such a huge, you know, resume. You've done so many films and television programs, et cetera. Do you love constantly kind of jumping into new things and going a completely different direction?
好吧，这说明了一些有趣的事情，杰夫。你喜欢那样吗？但显然你刚才说过你挺喜欢……杀青的那种感觉。但是，你有着如此丰富的……你知道的，履历。你拍过那么多电影和电视剧节目等等。你喜欢不断地跳进新的事物中，然后去往一个完全不同的方向吗？
Like your stuff, the breadth of your work is crazy. Yeah. Comedy, drama, indie, huge movies. Like theater. What is that about? I, I, I, it's keeping me interested, to be honest. The pandemic happened and I, I was 65 when the pandemic happened. So it really was like forced retirement without the gold watch.
就像你的作品，你的戏路之广简直疯狂。对。喜剧、剧情片、独立电影、大制作电影。还有戏剧。那到底是怎么回事？我，我，说实话，这让我保持兴趣。大流行发生了，而大流行发生时我65岁了。所以这真的就像是强迫退休，只是没有发金表。
You're just done. And this is what, oh, this is what retirement is like. I got it. Okay. And then I, I came out of, well, in March, almost out of the pandemic, we hope I went down to Pittsburgh and we've just finished five months of shooting this showtime series called American Rust. And I was curious as to whether I'd still be in love with acting or wanted to do it.
你就这样杀青了。这就是……哦，原来这就是退休生活。我懂了，好吧。然后我走出了……好吧，在3月份，差不多要走出大流行了（我们希望如此），我去了匹兹堡，我们刚刚完成了五个月的拍摄，这是一部名为《美国锈金》的Showtime剧集。我当时很好奇自己是否还热爱表演，或者还想继续演。
I was getting used to semi-retired and all that. And I missed it. I missed between action and cut. I miss, I missed even going back to Mockingbird, you know, on Broadway. I miss what Atticus Finch is going to be able to do to this post George Floyd crowd. Acting is a kind of thing, if just for me, if I just stay focused on acting, I can take 43 years of doing it and be better than I've ever been because it's cumulative, right? We're not athletes.
我当时正在习惯半退休状态之类的一切。但我怀念它。我怀念喊“开拍”和“停”之间的时光。我甚至怀念回到百老汇去演《杀死一只知更鸟》。我怀念苔丝·芬奇将对这个经历过乔治·弗洛伊德事件后的观众群体产生怎样的影响。表演就是这样一种东西，对我而言，如果我只专注于表演，我可以把43年的演艺经验积累起来，比我以往任何时候都要好，因为这是累积的，对吧？我们不是运动员。
Our bodies don't deteriorate. Or if they do, play your age, which is also what I'm doing. I'm still playing 20 to 25. Yeah. Thank God for Sean. Well, that's your, that's your choice. Sean's deteriorating one toe at a time. The market thing was funny.
我们的身体不会退化。或者如果退化了，那就演符合你年龄的角色，这也是我正在做的。我还在演20到25岁的角色。对。感谢肖恩。好吧，那是你的，那是你的选择。肖恩是一个脚趾一个脚趾地在退化。去集市那个梗真搞笑。
But I just, I'm still interested and I got to be challenged. I got to risk failure. I got to like, they're writing it for me, but I've never done this guy before. So I'm going to go all in on that and see if I can pull it off. And I, and if I do, I do affect and then I keep, whatever process I got is working and it comes from newsroom. How do you know if you've pulled it off? Do you, do you defer to the critics?
但我觉得，我还很有兴趣，我必须接受挑战。我必须冒着失败的风险。我必须像——剧本是为我写的，但我以前从未演过这家伙。所以我要全力以赴，看看我能不能成功。如果我成功了，那我就有影响，然后我就会继续，我用的任何方法都管用，它来源于《新闻编辑室》。你怎么知道自己成功了？你会，你会听从评论家的意见吗？
I bet no. Is it for yourself? Like in other words, do you watch what you do? And when you see the final product or the dailies or playback or whatever, are you the barometer? Are you the one that decides whether you've gone outside your skill set? If it's, if you're doing too much acting, if you're staying within yourself, how do you know if you're pulling off a character?
我敢说不会。这是为了你自己吗？换句话说，你看你自己的表演吗？当你看到最终成品、每日样片、回放或者其他什么时，你是那个晴雨表吗？你是那个决定你是否超越了自己技能范围的人吗？如果是，如果你演得太多，如果你有所保留，你怎么知道自己是否成功塑造了一个角色？
It's the work ethic. I had to work so hard on the first season of newsroom harder than I've ever had to work. You have to memorize mountains of dialogue and then you got to spit it out at a hundred miles an hour. That means you have to learn it so that you can do that the Sunday night before the entire week. You can't learn it in the makeup chair. You just can't.
是工作道德。《新闻编辑室》第一季我必须非常努力地工作，比我以往任何时候都要努力。你必须记住海量的台词，然后以每小时一百英里的速度像机关枪一样吐出来。这意味着你必须在全剧组开始过整个星期的那个周日之前，就把台词学得滚瓜烂熟。你不能在化妆椅上背台词。你根本做不到。
I've seen day players come in on newsroom and they're trying to learn three pages of sorkin in the makeup chair and the flop sweat hits them. I mean, it's, it's, it's really, I've never seen it anywhere else. They, they, and we all go through it. I went through it on episode five. I got in and I just couldn't keep a word of it in my head anymore. The computers overloaded and I literally took a knee in the middle of the newsroom and said, give me the line again.
我见过临时演员来到《新闻编辑室》，他们试图在化妆椅上背诵三页艾伦·索金的台词，然后他们就急得直冒冷汗。我是说，这真是，我从没在其他地方见过。他们，他们，我们都经历过。我在第五集时就经历过。我走进片场，脑子里再也记不住一个词了。电脑超载了，我简直是在新闻编辑室中央单膝跪地，说：“再给我一次台词。”
Give me the line again. And she gave it to me three times. Couldn't say it. They sent me home. Wow. Oh my God. We called it getting sorkinized. You just hit the wall and, and, and everybody, everybody did it.
“再给我一次台词。”她把台词给了我三次。还是说不出口。他们把我送回家了。哇。天哪。我们管这叫“索金化”。你就是撞墙了，而且，每个人，每个人都经历过。
I mean, I can go around the cash and go that day. Yeah. I remember when Allison, I remember when Tommy did all of us. So I knew the amount of work that I had to put in to pull off Will McAvoy every fucking day. I'd love to see Jason do that. Because Jason's memorization is, is, is the best of all, I think I'm good, but Jason's is the best of all time.
我是说，我可以数出那天剧组里的人。对。我还记得当艾莉森……我记得当汤米……我们所有人。所以我知道我每天为了演好威尔·麦卡沃伊必须付出多大的努力。我很想看杰森那样做。因为杰森的记忆力，是，是最棒的，我认为我不错，但杰森的是有史以来最好的。
But you know what though? I think that would be my kryptonite though. I wonder if I'd be any good at that to, to memorize things. Word perfect. That's not the way I, I do it. That's not the way I've memorized it. Many don't. And that's perfectly wonderful and fine.
但你知道吗？我觉得那会是我的软肋。我不知道我是否擅长这个——背东西。一字不差。这不是我的方式，我不是那样做的。这不是我记忆的方式。很多人不是。这完全很好，也很棒。
You know, it's just, this was, I had to do that. So I knew the amount of work I had to do to pull off season one of newsroom. I took that work ethic. Are we going to, are we going to sag in, in, I mean, I won the Emmy for that, that first season. And only because I had that Northwestern speech. No, I don't think that's the only reason I think you're, I think you're amazing. You're incredible.
你知道，这只是，我必须这么做。所以我知道为了演好《新闻编辑室》第一季，我必须付出多少努力。我把这种工作道德带到了……我们要，我们要陷入……我是说，我凭第一季拿了艾美奖。而且仅仅是因为我有那段西北大学的演讲。不，我不认为那是唯一的原因，我觉得你，我觉得你太棒了。你太不可思议了。
That was the episode that they submitted. And, and literally I'm, we're going to the Emmys and, and HBO was saying, look, just enjoy the meal. And you're not going to win, Gandalfini never won the first two seasons. So just, just, just enjoy the night. Okay. All right. You're up against Spacey in House of Cards and Damien Lewis and Homeland and John Hamm
那是他们送审的一集。而且，真的，我们要去参加艾美奖，HBO说：“听着，就享受这顿大餐吧。你不会赢的，甘多菲尼在前两季也从未获奖。所以，就，就，就享受这个夜晚吧。好吧。好吧。你的对手是《纸牌屋》的凯文·史派西、《国土安全》的达米安·刘易斯和乔恩·哈姆……”
and, and Mad Men, Brian in, in Breaking Bad. I mean, there was no way. It was that speech. That Northwestern speech. I can't believe that Aaron wrote your speech for you too. Your acceptance speech. That's so crazy that you had to do that perfectly as well. That was over the top.
“还有……《广告狂人》，《绝命毒师》的布莱恩。”我是说，根本不可能。就是那段演讲。西北大学那段演讲。我简直不敢相信艾伦连你的获奖感言都帮你写了。你居然也必须把那个演得天衣无缝，这太疯狂了。那简直太过分了。
Is that true? You had to pay him a hundred thousand for that. We'll be right back. All right. Back to the show. So Jeff, I want to go back to, to kill a mockingbird with Aaron Sorkin and Broadway. It broke some box office record or something like that, right? The top sales of all time or something.
真的吗？你得付给他十万美元版权费。我们马上回来。好的。回到节目中。杰森，我想回到百老汇和艾伦·索金合作的《杀死一只知更鸟》。它打破了什么票房纪录之类的吧？历年最高票房还是什么的？
That's incredible. We have the top, top 10 weekly grosses. We hold the top nine. Wow. Isn't that unbelievable? That's crazy. And, and do you guys, I don't know if I'm, this is a question to everybody, you know, because I come from theater, you come from theater.
这太不可思议了。我们拥有每周最高票房的前十名。我们占据了前九名。哇。这难道不是难以置信吗？太疯狂了。而且，你们，我不知道我是不是，这是个向所有人提问的问题，你知道的，因为我出身戏剧界，你也出身戏剧界。
That's where it all starts, right? So do you remember when Bravo used to air operas and plays and things like PBS used to air some great theater stuff and people watched them all the time as a kid. I used to watch them. Did they really? They, operas? They used to put them down? They used to do all that stuff.
这一切都是从那里开始的，对吧？所以你还记得当年Bravo电视台曾经播放歌剧、戏剧之类的节目，PBS也曾播放过一些精彩的戏剧节目，人们小时候经常看。我过去常常看。他们真的播过吗？歌剧？他们以前播过这些？他们以前做过所有这些东西。
Do you remember that, Jeff? Did you ever watch that? No, not specifically Bravo, but I did. I remember CBS Playhouse or not that I, you know, I'm old but not that old, but I remember seeing like Paul Newman as a young actor walking on to that, a show of CBS Playhouse directed by Sidney LaMette, you know, oh God, Ernest Borgnein as Marty, you know, they would do stuff like that. Yeah.
你还记得吗，杰森？你看过吗？不，不是特指Bravo，但我看过。我记得《CBS剧场》或者——倒不是说，你知道，我老了但没那么老，但我记得看到年轻演员保罗·纽曼走进那个由西德尼·吕美特导演的《CBS剧场》节目，你知道的，哦天哪，还有欧内斯特·博格宁演的《马蒂》，你知道的，他们会做那种节目。对。
Yeah. And I'll only use the Mockingbird experience is that it's different than watching the movie or reading the book and it's that you feel the play for a year, eight shows a week, proudly went Cal Ripken Jr. and didn't miss a show for a year. That's great. I was on a mission. That's great. That's great.
对。我只想说《知更鸟》的经历与看电影或读书不同，那就是你连续一年、每周八场戏地感受这部话剧，自豪地像卡尔·里普金二世一样，一年都没有缺席一场演出。太棒了。我当时肩负使命。太棒了。太棒了。
I remember doing God of Carnage with Gandalfini, Hope Davis, Margie Gehardt and we were doing I don't know, seven months and across the street was, they were doing West Side Story, I think, and Arthur Lawrence, 92 years old, they had to bring Arthur in because the 20 somethings were getting drunk on Tuesday night and skipping the Wednesday matinee. The actors. Yeah. Yeah. And Arthur came in and read him the riot act and there's just a thing and Henry Fonda
我记得和甘多菲尼、霍普·戴维斯、马吉·盖哈特一起演《杀戮之神》，我们演了，我不知道，七个月。街对面，他们当时在演《西区故事》什么的，92岁的阿瑟·劳伦斯，他们不得不把阿瑟请来，因为那些二十多岁的人在周二晚上喝醉了，翘掉了周三的日场。演员们。对。对。然后阿瑟走过来，把他们狠狠训斥了一顿。还有亨利·方达……
did Mr. Roberts for how many thousand performances, never missed, I'm going, that's, I'm aiming at that. I'm just going to go old school on that just to see if I could do it. The other thing too was to see if in the 10th and 11th and yes, 12th month of this show, does it die? Yeah. Do creatively, do you hit the wall and I can't repeat it and I can't do it anymore and phoning it in.
演《罗伯茨先生》演了多少千场演出，从未缺席，我就在想，那就是，我的目标就是那个。我要用老派的方式来做这件事，只是看看我能不能做到。另一件事是看看在第八、第九、甚至第十、第十一、是的，第十二个月的演出中，它会死掉吗？对。在创作上，你会撞墙，然后无法重复，再也演不下去，开始敷衍了事吗？
And I was happy to say that that did not happen. We were performing surgery at a hundred miles an hour. That was the time to see that show. It was at its best because we knew it cold. Yeah. And we just kept it alive, which is the thing is, it's this listening and reacting, which is a form of improv. It's just against the script and that's what we did.
我很高兴地说，那并没有发生。我们当时在以每小时一百英里的速度做一台外科手术。那是看那场演出最好的时候。它处于最佳状态，因为我们对它烂熟于心。对。我们只是让它保持活力，关键在于，这就是这种倾听与反应，这是即兴表演的一种形式。它只是对照着剧本，而这就是我们所做的。
You don't know what he's going to say next. So wait to hear what he or she says and then use that. Half your performance is in the other actor. If you do all that stuff, you can keep it alive enough that you don't hit a wall with it. That's, that's that old thing that they say, like acting is, acting is reacting or as Jason always says, acting is acting like you're reacting. But Sean, aren't you, Sean, aren't you planning, aren't you doing Iceman cometh on TikTok?
你不知道他接下来会说什么。所以等着听他或她说什么，然后利用这一点。你一半的表演都在另一个演员身上。如果你做了所有这些，你就能让它保持足够的活力，让你不会在上面撞墙。那就是他们常说的那句老话，比如表演就是，表演就是反应，或者正如杰森总是说的那样，表演就是假装你在反应。但是肖恩，难道你不是，肖恩，你不是在筹划，你不是要在TikTok上表演《冰人来了》吗？
Are you, are you planning to do that? And one minute, one minute bites. Oh, it's going to be so good. One more, one more question in the weeds about that. Just while you just said, you know, listening and then reacting, isn't that at odds with the sort of mandate to do the style of the fast talking, don't take any gaps, pick up your cues, order of the sort of Sorkinian or mammoth type of rhythm. I mean, isn't that at odds with hearing what the person just said, doing the proper acting
你，你打算这么做吗？用一分钟、一分钟的片段。哦，那一定太棒了。关于这个，还有一个，更深入的问题。就在你刚才说的时候，你知道，倾听然后反应，这难道与那种快节奏说话风格的要求不相矛盾吗？不要有任何空隙，接上你的对白，也就是索金式或那种宏大节奏的顺序。我的意思是，这难道不与听到对方刚说的话、进行恰当的表演相矛盾吗……
of having that information process, formulate an opinion, construct an answer, then spit it out. All of that timing certainly you need for comedy, but definitely in drama as well, that you're being asked to eliminate in the interest of just doing a speedy, this is the rhythm I as the writer want you to have. So it says, don't worry about your acting, service the rhythm of this writing. Do you know what I mean? Yeah, a mammoth wrote a book about that, which would piss me off because it was, you know,
需要让这些信息经过大脑处理、形成观点、组织答案、然后脱口而出。所有这些时机感你当然需要用于喜剧，但在戏剧中绝对也是需要的，而你被要求为了追求速度而消除这些，这就是我作为作家希望你拥有的节奏。所以它的意思是，别担心你的演技，去服务于这种剧作的节奏。你知道我的意思吗？对，有个大人物为此写过书，这会把我气死，因为那是……
don't act, just say my words, well, okay. But here's what Barnard Hughes was a great actor when I was coming up in the 70s and 80s. And he was in a show called Da, I wanted Tony for it. I think he was in midnight, he was, he was in midnight cowboy is that guy that ends up with John Voight somewhere. Anyway, but I asked Barney told me, and she goes, say a, think B, then say C. That's one way to do it.
别去演，只管说我的台词，好吧。但这就是伯纳德·休斯，当我在70年代和80年代初露头角时，他是个伟大的演员。他演过一出叫《达》的戏，我因此获得了托尼奖。我想他演过《午夜牛郎》，他就是那个最后和乔恩·沃伊特在一起的那个家伙。不管怎样，但我问巴尼告诉我，她说：说A，想B，然后说C。这是一种方法。
If you want to move, say a, and as you're thinking B, say C. And so that, that, that's how you beat it. And, and you know, when she, you're not here, the queue isn't the last two words of what he or she says, it's what they said in the middle. But sometimes it is sometimes you don't get the necessary information you need that lives in your response until the end of their last line. You know, like they don't, you know, so it's, I mean, I, you know, we're, we're in the weeds. Yeah.
如果你想行动，说A，当你在想B的时候，说C。所以，这就是你如何把握节奏的。你知道的，当你，你听到的不是他或她说的最后两个词，而是他们在中间说的话。但有时确实是，有时直到他们最后一句台词结束，你才得到回应中所需要的必要信息。你知道的，就像他们没有，你知道的，所以，我的意思是，你知道的，我们陷入了细节。对。
And then here's, no, no, no, no, and then here's what happens, Jason. That's how Aaron goes in because he doesn't want you bringing in all your things. He wants you to do it the way he wrote it. Okay, great. Now you're doing episodes. Now you're into the first season, maybe you're into the second and he trusts you. Now that pause that he wrote in there, you pitch. I'm not doing that.
然后，听着，不，不，不，不，然后发生了什么，杰森？这就是艾伦介入的方式，因为他不想让你带入你自己的所有想法。他想让你按他写的方式去做。好的，太棒了。现在你在拍剧集。现在你到了第一季，也许你到了第二季，他信任你了。现在他写在里面的那个停顿，你可以去争取。我不是那样做的。
I'm going right straight through, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh. He sees everything. He hears everything. And now you're doing not only what Aaron did and you're sticking to his words. That's the rule. But you're putting your own thing on it, which changes the way he does it. Because Aaron writes in front of a mirror, he, he writes out loud. He plays every part, which that's why you kind of, there's a sameness to it sometimes.
我要直接顺过去，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。他什么都看得到。他什么都听得到。现在你不仅在做艾伦做的事，而且你坚持他的台词。这是规则。但你把自己的东西融入其中，这改变了他做事的方式。因为艾伦在镜子前写作，他大声朗读出来。他扮演每一个角色，这就是为什么你有时会觉得有一种千篇一律的感觉。
But you, you, you're able to beat that by having me and Emily Mortar and Tom Sadosky and whomever else, you know, and, and they're doing it. It's different voices from the same voice. So it's, you know, that it's, it's, it's tricky. But eventually they, somebody like Sorkin will, will trust you to let you go. I mean, he never, he never came to me and, and gave me line readings or anything like that. Anything.
但你，你可以通过让我、艾米莉·莫迪默、汤姆·萨多斯基以及其他任何人来打破这一点，你知道的，而且他们在这样做。这是同一个声音发出的不同声音。所以，你知道的，这很棘手。但最终，像索金这样的人会信任你，让你自由发挥。我的意思是，他从来没有，他从来没有来找我，给我指导台词或类似的事情。任何事情。
The line through, the rehearsal was a line through at 6 30 in the morning, sitting in the newsroom. He'd have all eight of us sitting around there and I'd be off book. There's 13 pages of Sorkin and I'm standing there at 6 30 in the morning and the first day everybody's got their pages and they're looking at their pages and I'm just going around the room and I know all 13 of them. You guys are fucked. And then, and then the next day, everybody, nobody had any pages.
对白通读，排练是在早上六点半进行对白通读，坐在新闻编辑室里。他会让所有八个人围坐在那里，而我不需要剧本。有十三页索金的台词，我早上六点半站在那里，第一天每个人都拿着剧本，看着他们的剧本，而我只是在房间里走来走去，我知道全部十三页。你们死定了。然后，然后第二天，每个人，都没有剧本了。
Yeah. It's just survival on Sorkin. It's survival. So, I mean, this is, that's so intense and what an intense experience and it takes up so much of your life. Did you ever have times, especially then for, do you follow sports a lot? I see that you've got a lot of music behind, like instruments behind you. Like what do you do to kind of, you know, unwind?
对。在索金手下就是为了生存。这就是生存。所以，我的意思是，这太强烈了，这是多么强烈的经历，它占用了你生活的大部分时间。你有没有过这样的时刻，尤其是那时候，你经常关注体育吗？我看到你背后有很多音乐，比如乐器。你通常做些什么来放松呢？
Yeah. For the listener, he's, Jeff, you got like 75 guitars. Yeah. Beautiful. Yeah. I know. I have a home recording studio that I really enjoy. I've always played guitar and played it since the seventies.
对听众来说，杰森，你大概有75把吉他。对。很漂亮。对。我知道。我有一个我很喜欢的家庭录音室。我一直弹吉他，从70年代就开始弹了。
I never played out in a club or anywhere. I started playing in the seventies. I played out maybe the first time in 2002 and I just played on the porch. I was hanging around playwrights off Broadway in the seventies and I had never seen a living, breathing playwright before. I'm 21, I'm 22, I'm in New York, I'm at this theater company and every single one of these playwrights like Lanford Wilson are rewriting a second act. It was a living, breathing thing, the writing.
我从来没在俱乐部或其他任何地方公开表演过。我从70年代开始弹。我大概在2002年第一次公开表演，我只是在门廊上弹。70年代我在外百老汇的剧作家周围闲逛，我以前从未见过活生生的、会呼吸的剧作家。我21岁，我22岁，我在纽约，我在这个剧团里，每一个像兰福德·威尔逊这样的剧作家都在重写第二幕。那是活生生的、会呼吸的东西，写作。
I had, you know, in college, you just get a published script and the guy's either dead or I don't know, but that thrilled me. And so the writing thing interested me, directing, like it's, no, but the writing interested me, but I'm never going to get a play written and done on Broadway. So I'm going to pick up the guitar, get better at that. Oh, look, here's Doc Watson, here's Steve Goodman. Here's Arlo Guthrie. Now you're into the blues.
我，你知道的，在大学里，你只能拿到一个出版的剧本，作者要么已经死了，要么我不知道，但这让我很兴奋。所以写作这东西让我感兴趣，导演，就像是，不，但写作让我感兴趣，但我永远不会写出一出戏并在百老汇上演。所以我要拿起吉他，把那个练好。哦，看，这是多克·沃森，这是史蒂夫·古德曼。这是阿洛·格思里。现在你开始接触蓝调了。
Jonathan Edwards, Shani, funny, Christine Lavin writes funny, plays well. They stand there with an acoustic guitar on a stage for 100 minutes and they hold them. That's hard to do. And coming from musicals and high school and college, it was like, I knew how to do that where suddenly you break into song. I would just write and write and write and throw them in a notebook and just get better at the guitar and finger picking. And then eventually I had this theater company and we needed to raise money.
乔纳森·爱德华兹，肖恩，有趣，克里斯蒂娜·拉文写得有趣，弹得也好。他们拿着一把原声吉他站在舞台上一百分钟，就能把观众镇住。这很难做到。从音乐剧、高中和大学走出来，这就好像，我知道该怎么做，你会突然唱起歌来。我只会不停地写、写、写，把它们扔进笔记本里，然后把吉他和指弹练得更好。后来我有了这个剧团，我们需要筹集资金。
So why don't we put you on stage with your guitar and we can sell tickets? And that's a whole other deal. I had flop sweat. And it took, it's like the first time you do Carson or Letterman or Leno or Steve or any of the guys fall in, you know, it's seven minutes and you got a score. And flop sweat happens, you know, when you're out there for the first time or two on that. So it was the same thing. But once I learned how to do it, creatively I controlled everything.
所以为什么不把你和你的吉他推上台，这样我们就能卖票了？那是完全另外一回事。我紧张得出冷汗。这需要时间，就像你第一次上卡森、莱特曼、雷诺、史蒂夫或其他任何人的节目一样，你知道的，只有七分钟，你得表现好。当你第一次或第二次站在那个舞台上时，冷汗就会冒出来。所以是一样的。但一旦我学会了怎么做，我在创作上就掌控了一切。
There was nobody else telling me what to do, what to sing, what to say, what jokes were completely my own thing. And that was an escape. And so I just kept collecting the guitars and, you know, I've got too many, but you know, better than cocaine. Is your life as idyllic as it sounds right now? Can you get perspective on that? I mean, or does it just feel like yours?
没有人告诉我该做什么、该唱什么、该说什么，什么笑话完全是我自己的东西。那是一种逃避。所以我一直在收集吉他，你知道的，我有太多了，但你知道的，总比可卡因强。你现在的生活像听起来那么田园牧歌吗？你能对此有个客观的看法吗？我的意思是，还是它只是让你觉得这纯粹是你自己的生活？
I mean, do you treat yourself to take a step back and think, I'm happy, I'm healthy. I've had a long career in an incredibly fickle, you know, profession. And I've got this family and I'm living on a lake in Michigan. Yeah. At the beginning you said, I love when you said, how do you know you've made it? Is it awards? Is it acclaims? Is it money?
我的意思是，你会不会退后一步，心想：我很开心，我很健康。在一个极其善变的行业里，我有着漫长的职业生涯。我有这样的家庭，我住在密歇根的一个湖畔。对。一开始你说，我最喜欢你说的那句，你怎么知道你成功了？是奖项吗？是赞誉吗？是金钱吗？
It just feels like you've made it. You've made it. Yeah. We're here to tell you. Congratulations. Congratulations. Well, it's very nice. We let people know if they should be happier or not.
这只让人觉得你成功了。你成功了。对。我们是来告诉你这一点的。恭喜。恭喜。嗯，这很好。我们让人们知道他们是否应该更快乐。
You know what? You check out of the Ambition Hotel, you check out of the, where's that next thing? And I got to make more. And I got to do, I got to get, I got to get an, how do I get nominated for that? I just, it's sexy and different. But if you get to a certain point and you go, you know what? Pretty good. Yeah.
你知道吗？你退出了“雄心酒店”，你退出了那种“下一个目标在哪里？我得赚更多。我得去做，我得去得到，我怎么才能获得那个提名？”的生活。那很性感、与众不同。但如果你到了某个阶段，你会想：你知道吗？相当不错。对。
Pretty good. I can live with that. And if nothing else happened, and it really happened after Atticus on Broadway, that's where I felt that if it ended, I'm good. Yeah. I'm good. Yeah. Jeff, thank you so much for coming.
相当不错。我能接受这个。如果再没有发生别的什么，而且这确实发生在《杀死一只知更鸟》在百老汇上演之后，那就是我感觉如果这就结束了，我也很好了。对。我很好了。对。杰森，非常感谢你来。
I really truly meant what I said at the top. You are one of my all time favorites. I just revere you. I think you're incredible. Thank you. I appreciate that, guys. I appreciate that, guys. Very nice of you to say yes to this, Jeff.
我真的发自内心地认同我开头说的话。你是我有史以来最喜欢的演员之一。我由衷地敬仰你。我觉得你太不可思议了。谢谢。我很感激，伙计们。我很感激，伙计们。杰森，你能答应来这真是太好了。
You're a treasure. Thank you for coming. Thank you, guys. Yeah. Thank you, everybody. Bye. See you, Jeff. See ya.
你是个宝藏。谢谢你的到来。谢谢大家。再见。再见，杰森。再见。
Nice going, Sean. Yeah. Really good, Sean. Really, really good. God, I love that guy. I love him. I think he's great. You know, the thing that really stuck with me, that's why I brought it up at the end,
干得好，肖恩。对。真的很好，肖恩。真的，真的很好。天哪，我太喜欢那家伙了。我太喜欢他了。我觉得他太棒了。你知道，真正深深印在我脑海里的，这就是为什么我在最后把它提出来，
which was how do you know? When he said, how do you know you've made it? Is it a family? Is it the work? Is it the money? Is it what is it? Is it the car you've always wanted? Is it, you know, it's really?
那就是你怎么知道的？当他说，你怎么知道你成功了？是一个家庭吗？是工作吗？是金钱吗？到底是什么？是你一直想要的汽车吗？是你，你知道的，真的是吗？
Chicks. It's chicks. It's chicks. Sorry. It's chicks. Yeah. It's, I do, not to take this down into a dark hole, but, you know, being past 50, it's like, well, if I want to live to be 100, then I've got to admit that I'm on the second
辣妹。是辣妹。是辣妹。对不起。是辣妹。对。我是说，倒不是想把话题引向一个黑暗的深渊，但是，你知道的，年过五十之后，就像是，好吧，如果我想活到100岁，那么我必须承认我已经进入了下半场。
half and you start to think about, how am I doing with the years I've been given? Am I using them well? Because eventually you're going to be inside that last year or last 10 years or whatever, and you're going to start to think back. And at that point, it's going to be too late to change what you've done with the time you've been given, and it's all of those things, right? I always, yeah, I think all the, first of all, two things. One is, I remember one time, this is years ago, thinking about this, there's a guy that
你开始思考：我度过的这些年过得怎么样？我好好利用它们了吗？因为最终你将身处最后一年或最后十年左右的日子里，你会开始回想。到了那个时候，再去改变你用所给予的时间所做的事情就太晚了，所有这些都是这样，对吧？我一直，对，我认为所有，首先，两件事。一是，我记得有一次，这是几年前的事了，想到这一点，有一个家伙我曾经非常崇拜他作为某种喜剧演员，他太棒了，我不打算说出他的名字，但是，而且我记得当时想，他，你能看出来他觉得自己已经成功了。现在他认为自己很搞笑，而我想，我总是这样想：当你觉得自己已经掌握了诀窍的那一刻，就是你失去它的时候。
I used to really look up to as a sort of comedic actor, and he was amazing, and I'm not going to name his name, but, and I remember thinking like, he, you could tell that he thought that he had made it. And now that he thought he was funny, and I thought, I always think about this, the moment that you think that you've got it is the moment that you've lost it. Yeah. And so you always have to stay, you always have to sort of stay humble, and I know it's people are going to be like, yeah, nice try, asshole actor as they're driving or walking
对。所以你必须始终保持，你总是需要保持谦逊，我知道人们会觉得：得了吧，好一个装腔作势的混蛋演员，当他们开车或走路时。这是真的，你总是必须，你永远不必，永远不要用第三人称来考虑自己，永远不要，我也记得听人说过，永远不要把“我的”和“职业生涯”这两个词连在一起用，比如，不要谈论，我尽量不那样看待自己。我试图，我唯一的责任——我会把这个话题再深入探讨一下——我一直觉得我每天唯一的责任就是快乐，无论在哪里都要寻找快乐，专注于那些行之有效的事情。
or whatever. It's true, you always have, and you never have to, never think about yourself in the third person, never, also I remember hearing somebody say, never use the words, my and career next to each other, like, don't talk about, and I try not to think about myself in that way. I tried to, my only responsibility, and I'll go even further down this road is, I always feel like my only responsibility every day is to be happy and look for joy wherever I can and focus on the things that work.
如果我这样做，如果我在日常生活中寻找那种东西，你知道的，我们生活中都有行不通的事情，但如果95%的事情都在正常运转，为什么还要专注于那5%没用行不通的呢？对我和我来说，这就是我每天尽量去做的，再说一次，别弄得太，你知道的，我只是希望你能停止靠吃甜甜圈来让自己开心，你知道吗，太棒了，那是油炸面团。肖恩觉得这很棒，肖恩觉得这是一种美妙的、第三人称的情感，肖恩已经准备好收尾了。
And if I do that, if I look for that kind of stuff in everyday life, you know, we all have things that don't work in our lives, but if 95% of the stuff is working, why focus on the 5% that's not? And for me, that's what I try to do on a daily basis, again, not to get too, you know, I just wish you'd stop looking at donuts to make you happy, and you know what, so good, it's fried dough. Sean thinks that that's wonderful, Sean thinks that that's a wonderful, third person, sentiment and Sean's ready to wrap this up.
对，你知道的，肖恩正在想办法把“拜”这个词编进对话里，对吧？你想顺便用上它。而你所想的，一旦嘉宾离开，你只想赢得“拜”的比赛。对。对。你根本没在听我们说话。你就像是在谷歌搜索带有“拜”的词。
Yeah, you know, Sean's thinking of a way to braid in the word by, aren't you? You're trying to back into it. And all you think about when, as soon as the guest goes away, you just try to win the by contest. Yeah. Yeah. You're not listening to what we're saying. You're like Googling things, Ryan's with by.
但我必须说“拜拜”，我必须去“尿尿”“拜拜”。哦，我必须去上个厕所。我的意思是，那就像是，我是说，你不能走，在我们想出一个有价值的“拜”之前你都不能走。那可真是一次彻底的投降。那简直太糟了。我憋尿憋得太厉害了。听着，肖恩，如果百老汇有什么剧目你能演的话，因为你知道，所有这些关于百老汇的讨论，会是《小可爱》吗？
But I have to go by, by, I have to go pee pee by, by. Oh, I have to make a potty. I mean, that was like, I mean, you can't go, you can't go until we come up with a worthwhile by. What a fucking surrender that was. That was like the worst. I have to pee so bad. Listen, if there was any show that you could do on Broadway, Sean, because you know, all
那倒挺聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
this talk about Broadway, would it be baby birdie? That'll do smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。下一集将在两周内发布，你可以在你收听播客的任何地方收听，或者现在就在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，也可以通过订阅Wondry App上的Wondry Plus来收听。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. The next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music, or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry App. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明. 聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。